[Music]
the best day I'm like I love games that
turn people against each other I want to
make out with them and choose eyebrows
on they should be rewarded for not being
people I hate people I don't care about
that prize but I'm gonna win because I
want his happiness to go away my
instinct is to be mean to you
whoever speaking in Spanish please use
the formal it's dead I don't even want
to be here the air is too fresh it's
disgusting I can't breathe there's a
brook somewhere that won't stop babbling
shut up no I didn't win but every sudden
make any new friendships that's gross I
love it I declare that everything you
are saying is stupid it's like talking
about people behind their backs
everybody wins
alcohol is delicious and fun don't try
to bond with me
I really don't care what happens to them
or anyone
hate talking to people about things this
is a nightmare
I don't want to do things I want to not
do things just like you taught me
someone will die Oh fun and there's
gonna be beer I'm Janet snake-hole I'm a
very rich widow with a terrible secret
who are you
macaroni and poison it's like mac and
cheese but with a special ingredient I'm
going to murder you a thousand times
come on time is money money is power
powers pizza pizzas knowledge let's go
and horizons are dumb it never broaden
your horizons hope someone when I hate
everything he loves last week he was
supposed to buy gas but instead he
bought novelty cookie cutters now
everything we eat is shaped like a
dinosaur
he's amazing look at me you were going
to pass us us and you were going to
become a cop and if you don't I'll just
divorce you and marry someone else and
then cheat on them with you I guess I
kind of hate most things but I never
really seemed to hate you when Andy
proposed to me he gave me a ring pop but
then he ate it first adults are boring
and I hate them and I don't want to buy
all the stupid boring adult stuff and
become boring adults hey listen to me
yes we're gonna get a dish rack and
shower curtains and a cutting board but
if you think for one second I'm not also
gonna get that marshmallow shooter so
that I can shoot you in the face with
marshmallows when you're asleep
you're the dumbest one right now
I'm gonna make me cry I found a dead
rabbit on the side of the road and I cut
his feet off and made it into a lucky
track baby you are so creepy thank you
Alwine tastes the same and if you spend
more than five dollars on wine you are
very stupid I wasn't listening but I
strongly disagree with an hood why does
everything we do have to be cooked in
like 15 layers of irony I wanted to make
fun of stupid people while I get drunk
my two true passions could only things I
like are dogs sleeping late and weird
birthmarks you can't make museums about
those I need scotch mark cigarettes why
I want to put them on sock signs April
No
so you've gone insane that's fun I only
tell the truth when it makes me sound
like I'm lying this suit makes me want
to scold a Catholic child be responsible
adult sucks but
[Applause]
[Music]
you